lost on you I keep clicking these
viruses because I keep downloading hello
are you here yeah I'm here I'm here I
thought I lost you I I don't know what
happened okay
you never drink any water is it because
you're a robot no no I have like two
beverages on my desk
soda those are not good for you no soda
no this is sparkling water I I almost
never drink I love soda like I love root
beer and stuff but I almost never do it
[Music]
okay now last time we sort of focused
primarily on handling past pawns I
tortured you with some very tactical end
games today we're gonna do kind of a mix
um we're gonna start with a really cool
warm-up study that's kind of
mind-blowing and one of my favorites
this should be famous but isn't then
we're gonna Focus today a little bit
more on Concepts and kind of developing
conceptual thinking so it won't be quite
as tactically torturous although there
will still be a lot of things to
calculate and hopefully it'll be fun
yes sir Captain it will be fun
aye aye yes all aboard okay so this is a
study by uh the search of brothers from
the 1920s it's white to play and draw
and white is going forward so C8 equals
Queen is possible in this position
okay oh I see but the issue is that The
Bishop's gonna come pin us oh could you
let me make arrows awesome okay so yeah
like Tanya said we can promote in a move
but he will just pin us and then we will
be just two behind this pawn and then we
can't stop him he'll push he's
Unstoppable just like us in the streamer
Awards or if you want a troll or if you
want a troll go B6
that's true we would troll a little bit
yeah
um good
so okay
I will think I will think and you should
enjoy your tabouli I will thank you as
long as you need no rush at all yeah if
you could think aloud that
um
what about okay also just came to my
head the problem is that The Bishop's
coming here so what if we just did this
um preventing it he would have probably
defend it with his King with this guy
so he would probably bring this guy here
or here maybe it's better to bring the
king towards my king towards the
opposition so I would guess maybe E4 is
better and now this is still a threat so
now we think
um let's see so we still can't push
um there's really no way to prevent that
and there's nothing we can promote we
can never get in a check
to move the king oh we're supposed to
draw we're not looking for a win right
so looking for a drop
well this might just not be it this this
is just the end of the line and it
probably just doesn't work
yeah King E6 King E4 loses and I could
show this on the board uh because at
this point black simply pre-moves Bishop
F5 and you know we're back to square
zero and process of elimination is
actually a super powerful tool in a lot
of end games because it it forces you to
consider moves that may appear totally
illogical and that's going to be one of
the themes of today's lesson is
essentially forcing yourself to look at
everything even stuff that seems
self-evidently bad
so anything of that nature here
okay my second thought is well how else
can you get the king to stop this Pawn
we can't go this way so if this is too
slow but the idea would be D6 C5 and
then B6 it might be too slow but if I
did this and he I'm not gonna make the
move actually I'll make the most if I
did this and he pushed we would be able
to stop him so he's not gonna push so
yeah
black has to play Bishop F5 to stop the
c-con yeah
stop in the pond now King C5 continue
the plan
black for example
Blaze Bishop C8 defending right and the
problem that you're going to run into is
that here I'm going to start moving my
king back and every time you slip to A7
I immediately start pushing B5 gotcha
and if you do not work and if you chill
out Chill on B6 then black will
eventually you know shoulder your king
and win the C7 Pawn I hate when we get
shouldered yeah incredibly annoying
principle you wouldn't know anything
about that would you boxing yeah never
done that
would you ever do chest boxing Donya
nah I think that's I've been going out
of my comfort zone more more and more in
the last couple of years but I I'm but
I'm just curious what what does that
mean going out of your comfort zone hey
I've been dancing on stream ah you know
these toxic these toxic streamers beat
me in a match and then they made me
Dance I mean can you believe that I
don't even know if it was you because
the face didn't make it into the videos
just a fraction everybody so we don't
really know if you did the punishment or
not for Dale nerdinski to dance in front
of a public is you you have to
understand how much this stuff this year
has been big for you that's fair maybe
we'll make you box next year
well we'll see about that process of
elimination is taking place what have we
eliminated well King E6 King D6
eliminated C8 Queen eliminated
now is the part where you have to
consider the Absurd moves so what move
appears like the most absurd possible
move white could play
like King Y8
even more absurd than that the most
counterproductive move
count it gets worse than King at King D
oh King C8 don't see it seems like the
worst move in the position in front of
your pawn and you're forcing Black's
Pawn forward what could be more
illogical than that move right yes yes
now black pushes the pawn two squares
because if black defends it with their
Bishop then you play what move and draw
immediately
we play a king V8 attacking the pawn if
they defend we could win it and draw
very good otherwise black loses because
you promote so black plays in the
initial position the move B5
now the beauty of the study is revealed
this is a pretty mind-blowing concept
so it appears self-evident that we're
gonna move our King black is gonna stop
our Pawn right and that's it we're not
going to be in time to stop black spawn
but here the ready the ready concept as
I like to call it comes in handy
they're ready good thing I've never
played the ready so one idea I had was
well is there any stalemate
possibilities we get the king to eight
there isn't so that's not it
um I mean this guy's just gonna push
obviously as soon as we move the King
The Bishop's coming here to prevent this
right
um
Bang
oh no it doesn't work
I was thinking like okay anywhere here
he just plays this what if we tried this
I was a bit looking at maybe King D7
coming soon
he pushes
now you need to do the same thing but
you need to somehow win a temper with
your king
how do you win a Tempo well there's only
one way to win a temple you need to
attack the bishop
no I didn't have it I had moment but it
wasn't right attack the bishop so please
correct bring the king towards E5
exactly here right here black chucks you
oh
um okay yep King D6 black pushes
and they're the critical move exactly
Bingo and then we tacked bishop and then
as Magnus recently learned we can enter
the square exactly yeah I also feel like
I never use this Square yes yes that
would be Magnus
yeah that was that was fun before and
was it on the stream with you that Magna
said he doesn't did he say he doesn't
know the rule of this or like he doesn't
use the rule of the square well the Joe
see I as I learned with you Dania you
really just don't consume any chess
content so Alex has been we've been
posting a lot of shorts on YouTube like
educational ones and Alex has just been
pumping out all the educational chest
shorts like this the rule of the square
and and Alex was playing him in a match
and he said thanks Alex without your
video I wouldn't have known it
wow while she in the timeouts match but
you need to we need a education of Chess
memes it would be good for you you
should do it Dania learns chess memes I
can teach you my culture and you can
teach me how to play chess
that sounds like a deal
um and then you'll teach me chess boxing
you know yes and we'll let I'll be next
year follow me into that world get you
out of your comfort zone so just to tie
up the study King E5 attacks the bishop
and I'll show you why I call it the
ready uh concept the bishop has to move
because B3 you take the bishop and you
promote and after the bishop moves no
matter where it moves
what are you going to do here
and what's the prettiest excellent
Bang
and now it's ours it's ours for the
taking that is how white draws but the
craziest thing to just do me is the
solution involves literally wasting a
Tempo and forcing the pawn forward
and the mat like The Logical reason why
is that when the pawns on B7 you like
you can't approach it with your king
yep so so you have to get the tempo
attacking the bishop now I have a
question for you yeah so like the way
you solve these are like really abstract
solutions that I don't feel like really
any patterns so I guess kind of like the
similar theme in all of your puzzles
like they're all just
problem solving like trying to be
creative when it comes Solutions
but yeah like how would you describe
stuff from this thought process that you
can use going forward into other puzzles
well I mean first of all I think I'm
going to show you why I call it the
ready concept and I think that the truth
of the matter is that end games actually
do subject themselves to logic
um and this is going to be the theme of
the subsequent exercises that I give you
this was more of just sort of a cool
warm-up study
um but what I kind of want you to draw
your attention to is the fact that you
know a lot of Physicians they seem very
overwhelming and it seems like there's
no pattern but you can Often by making
you know incisive observations you can
often guide yourself logically to a move
that just when you see the move without
any explanation may just seem like some
sort of computer move or uh something
illogical but in fact there's often like
a hidden logic uh to even complicated
ideas in the end game so here for
example that pattern is stems from this
study you've probably seen this before
so let's see if you see that I have this
is tell me all the end games and this is
very hard ready and this is a super like
important end game position so it's
white to play and draw
and you'll pick up on the similarity
between this and the study we just did
very quickly
um why to play and draw black is going
this way
immediately I'm thinking we want to
bring the king somehow this way so that
we're threatening both to get in the
square and to defend our Pawn exactly so
we go diagonally go ahead
Papa botas actually didn't show me this
one this is the the ready one you were
saying or no this is the ready study
yeah why is it called Ready oh it's
because it was composed by rehard ready
who of of you know ready Fame
uh and if H3
no no no no you have to be careful yeah
um
oh oh you're actually
yeah you play here and then here you
need access to the D7 Square to roll out
the red carpet for the pawn
and if of course I go King B6 now the
second part
of this concept
um can hear because if you take that I'm
in the square and if you push then I
defend like this exactly King here if
you take King F4 if H3 King D6 H2 and
finish it off
nice oh King first
careful no no no oh my God I'm not even
thinking okay yeah we push we only bring
the king if we need to exactly King B7
and King D7 with a truck and King so you
can spot the the similarity where you
basically multitask right you support
your Pawn or you you win a Tempo
essentially and use that Tempo to stop
your opponent's past Pawn got it
it's got it um yep so okay
right so if you're like familiar with
that concept that's the concept that uh
stands for that position but you're
right like obviously is this super
common in actual tournament practice not
really but this was more of a tactical
warm-up now we're going to consider a
couple of positions where I think we
will be able to uh derive specific
Concepts and actionable tips based on
those positions okay so I mean I think
even these I mean this type of concept
when it comes to problem solving I'm
sure you would use it because sometimes
you mean a position that you think
you're completely losing like how far
away the king is from the pawn you just
have to think a little more out of them
yeah and I'm sorry there's stuff that
applies it more generally I think if you
solve a ton of endgame studies you just
sort of develop the abstract ability to
find endgame tactics and end game
tactics are like one of the most
difficult aspects of Chess in general
because I think your brain just sort of
automatically assumes that with very few
pieces left on the board there's no
tactical potential but that could not be
further from the truth that's actually a
super important aspect of end game
Mastery there's so many tricks in the
end game
so let's start with a pretty simple
position but an instructive one
nonetheless this is from the pro chess
League from the last week of the protest
League
uh are you playing in that I am
unfortunately my team has lost the first
two weeks
so we are one strike away from losing
so so the first week we played magnus's
team we played the Canada chess for us
that's a good reason
but we were so freaking close we lost by
one point
um and it was right there
uh it's Everybody Plays everybody so I
played Magnus uh a wonder who's on our
team you know I wonder Liang
he was just killing Magnus it was
completely winning had he won that game
we would have won the match but when
you're winning against Magnus you know
how you feel it's just your hands shake
and your brain stops working
so that was unfortunate spaghetti then
second week we all played terribly and
lost to Brazil
to Brazil we've I don't know why but
Brazil's only the whenever I get
chess.com challenges from Brazil just I
get extra motivation because we've been
farmed by them so many times yeah no
those their GMS are so strong chess.com
players
yeah no for sure same thing at the GM
level so we lost and yeah we're one
strike away from getting knocked out but
we're still gonna fight
um but if you and you guys are still in
if we win we're still in yeah three
strikes and you're and you're out of the
regular season well you know if you need
some extra backup I'd happily play for
you guys I appreciate it we might lost
the Finish Line I beat a couple 2700s
you know on demand yep with well with
your newly acquired endgame knowledge I
don't think anybody stands a chance yes
yes this is a simple position again but
a good illustration of an incredibly
important endgame principle that applies
across almost all end games so it is
black to play just looking at this kind
of abstractly oh sorry white plays King
E5 and here it's black to play who is
playing for a win here just intuitively
white clearly what factors can you
identify that guide your intuition in
that regard bass clicking is more
advanced
they're in Black's half of the
Ender ponds on the uh
on the left side of the Border more
dense
and and in terms of the bishop placement
and the targets only black has a Target
what is that Target
the F7 Pawn the F7 Pawn exactly so
here's the principle and this is
essentially two principles packaged into
one when you're on the defending side of
an end game any end game your kind of
default approach should be to do nothing
the first question you should ask
yourself is what happens if I do nothing
and only if you've identified a specific
winning plan for your opponent should
you be looking for active counter play
and even more importantly in the end
game you should always avoid unnecessary
Pawn advances you should only push upon
if there is a super compelling reason to
do that pushing a pawn in order to
create a threat is often a trap uh that
causes more weaknesses to be created and
gives hands your opponent kind of the
winning plan
so let's apply that to this position how
would you go about defending this with
black
yeah well the first questions if we did
nothing what would White's plan be
um
I I'm trying to think if there's any way
they could break through like
could they break through here I don't
think this is a threat
um the king just can't enter any other
way so and even if they brought the king
over here to defend then we would gain
the space so it feels like the only way
light would pass is if I give them an
entry point thrown in these three
squares for the king
and then should we push any pawns wait
sorry what was the question about
pushing the pods so what would you just
more open-ended what would you play with
black hair
uh
uh see I don't want to move my I'd move
the bishop because I don't need to
unnecessarily push my bonds and I don't
want to move my king so we just move the
bishop move the bishop let's say to B7
and what's funny is that even if white
offers a bishop trade this is a bit of a
trick question because I think it's
counter-intuitive can you take the
bishop
last time I got asked a trick question
the trick was that there's no trick
exactly so I don't know I don't I don't
know how to trust my coaches anymore I
have trust issues
um if I take you take I mean this will
look bad but I guess you would have you
would take the opposition actually yep
so I could just take yeah you take King
takes King D7
I can try before to put you in zugsvong
but this F7 Pawn is actually on an
incredible spot how would you continue
with the black
um take take
here we go there's that rule in action
yeah we don't oh we don't push the pawns
if we don't need to
we don't push the pause if we don't need
to take is correct
but now a tough move to play I think
just intuitively
which way do you go we have to move the
king oh
wait
okay so either this way or this way if I
come here then you're gonna try to come
catch this Pawn so then the question is
can I take this guy and promote before
you could take these guys and promote
things
thing so I come here you play here I
play here you play here Bang Bang
take King comes here King comes here and
then I have one two three four five oh
God that does not work not fast enough
not fast that doesn't work
so then if I come here you come here
trying to take this guy
um how could we possibly promote if I
push oh I mean that's this is way too
slow so that's just that's not it
which line are you looking at sorry King
C7 King E5 or are we looking at the
other way
I looked at both and it looks like both
don't work but I could be wrong no that
you're right the pawn races are all
losing for black but again yeah your
default is passive defense right because
even when your king is at the most
passive spot possible sometimes your
opponent just can't make progress so if
you look carefully after King C7 King E5
yeah what is the sort of
you know this is a very difficult move
to play psychologically but it draws on
the spot
yeah ah the King goes back
the game goes back to D7 and after King
F6
oh this is cool King F6 tying the pawn
we defend from here yep and then if we
push then we just have opposition here
and if the King goes back then we just
we do down near his favorite thing and
we dance easy Clapton yeah we follow the
king and if white tries to quote unquote
shoulder you here there's nothing to
shoulder because F7 is safely defended
by Black's King so how would you
proceed here with black
um here exactly King let's say King G8
we dance and opposition I think is a
pretty overrated Concept in a lot of
Pawn end games where you cannot assume
that just because one side has the
opposition you're in zuzvong that's it's
more complicated than that here as you
know we've just reached the position
that uh that we basically started with
so black skin Shadows whites King add
infinitum
yeah these ones are very interesting
because it's stuff that like based on
your intuition you would look at first
and you'd be like this is just
completely losing yep because the move
like this like it just looks like
White's way more advanced you're gonna
lose this but yeah it's actually
interesting because I mean in these
scenarios the only way you could really
make the right decision is just through
calculation because there's no like
intuition here yeah and I mean the the
big intuitive principle I think is is
the concept of moving unnecessary but
what do you think black played here and
this is a decisive mistake but it's it
can be very tempting
yeah let's see uh probably push one of
these guys she played B5
yeah
and you're like attacking the bishop I'm
actually very curious how this is losing
but I'm guessing because now like The
Bishop's a weakness because that's the
same defend the pawn so it's more that
you've pushed the pawn on another light
Square so if this Pawn can be fixed on
B5 then white can approach it with his
King but how did you gain a Tempo here
with white another very important
principle if you have a bishop and game
a night end game working game you cannot
you have to assume that every time a
pawn moves the resulting Pawn end game
might have a different evaluation so
just because the plot end game with the
pawn here was a draw doesn't mean that
it's still a draw if the pawn was pushed
forward oh that okay so we would try to
trade the Bishops bingo uh-huh in this
case the king can get these pawns
exactly Bishop D5 is a super important
move this gains a Tempo because black
has to move the bishop back
and now a very strong positional move
fixing a pawn and a Wix weak Square ah
before simply before very good okay
because it's on the light squares it's
on a light Square now phase two is to
approach the B5 Pawn with your pieces
but because you're more active that's
much easier to do so black
has to stay put
yeah how would you reshuffle your bishop
and your king but be careful
if you give up territory you might allow
black a fortress yep exactly if we try
to come like this we could give black
this Square precisely precisely
um
ah this is cool Bishop B7 and then maybe
then you bring the king this way so that
you shoulder the king and then you bring
this bishop to A6 that is one way to
where there's many way you can bring the
bishop back you can put it on B7 anyway
um four works too yeah but Bishop B7 I
think is good enough the basically King
D7 King uh King D5 C5 and then Bishop C6
or A6 is going to end the game there's
nothing to calculate here if black tries
this there's actually a funny line the
way you put the ooh maybe bringing the
bishop back is a little bit more
accurate yeah I found the one way to
lose this no I think you still wins oh
because the Kingdom's here
and then Bishop A8 I think might keep an
advantage
yeah so it's just more difficult well no
oh yeah because then after Bishop B8 you
would trade the Bishops okay yeah it's a
little more complicated yeah it's still
winning and King B6 you obviously go to
the other way but I think uh in the game
I I don't even have the notation I think
Bishop before was played and basically
just here here and what's the next move
gonna be
Bishop D3 yeah Bishop D3 or Bishop C6
you pick up the pawn and the rest is
yeah
yep the rest is very easy nice this is a
very nice analysis putting on yeah
pushing unnecessary Pawns in general
something that you have to avoid
um so let's consider another Bishop end
game also from the PCL where 2700 very
good very good Blitz tips for end games
because I always panic
and push pawns and of course there's no
way to sugarcoat it like by the time you
get to an end game you're often in a
Time scramble there's no way to avoid
like a lot of mistakes in the end game
but developing your intuition does help
you you know often avoid stepping on
certain landmines and sometimes helps
you figure out wins very quickly
so let's consider the following position
all right
you see it
it is another same colored Bishop
all right this is uh both sides had a
couple of seconds at this point
oh wow and obviously it seems
self-evident the white is playing for a
win right because white is up a pawn yep
but what obstacles could you identify in
terms of trying to break down Black's
Fortress
well their pawns are all on Black and
White ponds aren't white so yeah
actually even though we have space our
pawns are much easier to attack
right
um so how does that actually hurt white
what the it restricts the mobility of
what piece the bishop right if let's say
white plays some nonchalant move like
Bishop F3 black will immediately respond
with
Bishop B3 taking the pawn bishop B3 and
actually white that's the best way to
lose right because if you lose A4 you
probably lose the game yep now white
could try it white could try to break
down the king side with what move this
move is useless but you could try it
um like G6
well H6 and we're talking from White's
perspective oh sorry ah white wants to
break down their King side yes but this
doesn't help at all and what you should
remember about Bishop end games in
particular is that if you put your King
on the opposite color of your opponent's
Bishop that is often an insta Fortress
because the king can never be moved from
E7 so white literally has no way to make
progress here you literally just shuffle
your Bishop back and forth and there's
no way through ah wait this is wait can
you you said the King on the opposite
side of the bishop what did you mean by
that yeah like a king on a dark square
if your opponent is a light squared
Bishop no oh you're saying oh got it
sorry okay and that allows you same with
opposite color Bishop end games that
allows you to build up an immediate
blockade yeah this is an easy Fortress
the pawns are in Black the king won't be
able to enter to attack these pawns and
this king's not moving gotcha exactly so
white concluded that there is no way
forward and basically repeated moves
with King F4 King G5 it turns out that
there is a really really cool winning
sequence here that's basically pure
tactics and I think you're able to find
this win again if you force yourself to
consider a move that seems to have an
obvious refutation but if you look at
that resulting position for a couple of
seconds I think you very quickly spot
the follow-up continuation
so what move could I be talking about
here
I mean there's not many options you
either bring your king back well I was
thinking like should we is it worth
calculating if there's any tactics
tricks over here also with this bishop
G4 but I know we already uh disregarded
this one
we disregarded which move
the bishop G4 but I was gonna I was
debating calculating stuff just because
it looks like maybe if there's a way we
could
Jake the king and try to push one of
these pawns but okay but that was part
of the trick right we disregarded it
from a general standpoint but we still
need to look completely at the move
Bishop G4 because that offers a bishop
trade which makes sense from a logical
perspective
yep the pandem game is obviously lost so
how is black gonna respond
here and this is the position if you
just kind of stare at it for a couple of
seconds you'll find something oh wait ah
I think I think I think Bishop here
because you take I push King comes here
and the King comes here oh actually I
don't think this works because then you
would attack our Pawn I was thinking
yeah yeah you can eliminate the
middleman though like Bishop D7 actually
doesn't
like what you can oh we don't need that
move right yeah you just push you push
immediately
why because if black takes then oh wow
this is very nice Bishop takes takes
takes and now we take this pawn and
promote exactly and that's just the
beginning that's step one
so in the game
I didn't find this but oops sorry oops
perhaps white even saw Bishop G4 and E6
the thing is black is not going to
cooperate nor is black going to leave
this G7 Pawn unattended black is gonna
step back to f8
stay on the dark squares and the problem
is that if you make the obvious move to
me the obvious move is team G6 yeah the
problem here is that black is going to
take and it does look winning for white
at first you can try what typical Motif
push
yes takes
takes but where is Black gonna put his
Bishop
and why is that going to be a problem
here and then what is black gonna do
um Pink push well we would have to oh oh
they have a passer yeah yeah
and we have no way to dislodge the
Bishop from this diagonal
yep and that's the bishop and you
promote well I mean this is really just
also yeah well I guess there's no way
that the slight squared Bishop could
have stopped this Pawn so that also
makes a difference and even if it could
you can imagine that what Black's King
is gonna basically win his pee Pawn
because you cannot use your Bishop to
stop the pawn and defend B5 at the same
time so it's at least a drop got it it's
at least a drop but same principle
applies white has a move here that wins
on the spot
and if you look at the position
carefully and consider the other
candidate moves it's a tactic and the
Tactical concept is common in the middle
game but not as common in the end game
is it H6 it is H6 yay this is a nice one
and if G takes H6
and we have deflection here
simple deflection yeah wait yeah is this
not it that's it that's it that's it
okay okay that's it
wait oh what is the definition of
deflection
uh so it could mean several similar
things oh right ready to diverse right
divert a piece from its control over a
certain Square gotcha gotcha nice and
yeah now that our light squared Bishop
could attack this Square it's easy and
if they sack we would just take with the
King and win this end game and Bingo and
just to finish it off Bishop takes A4
what's the best move order here
um the most forcing
yeah and it's the only winning move
actually hear and check because if we
started with the bishop then you take
the pawn and now
yeah now now it's very very easy
exactly
so very nice so we start with Bishop G4
Paradise very nice we consider a
position that seems to be pretty much
absurd but once you look at it a little
bit more carefully you can see quickly
that you're able to make progress with
the movie six
yep
um okay so let's apply that to a really
fun end game a pawn end game
end games can be fun oh they can be they
are are fun at all times and we're gonna
see the exact same thing in action where
at first you make a couple of obvious
moves and apply an important Pawn end
game principle then you reach a critical
position and it's all about forcing
yourself to calculate the move that
seems to self-evidently not work
there is the starting position
against lazovic and it's white to play
in this position
now yeah oh sorry this is very funny
because in these positions it's fun to
play what looks like the worst position
in the board but when I do it in my
Blitz Games it just ends into a very
tilting downward spiral so we'll see how
this translates into the Blitz
I'll take away the other lessons from
this
but no and I think you'll you'll you'll
you'll crack the the secrets of this
position pretty quickly so it's white
Supply
okay um and I just by the way I randomly
came up with an interesting idea if we
do part three what I might actually do
is go through your Blitz Games and sort
them and and I can do that on chess
space basically identify all the end
games and we can go over some like
constructive mistakes that you made uh
we're gonna have a lot a lot of a lot to
unload there I don't know if you want to
sign up for I like I think there was one
time I even said oh God my life's so
sorry no worries
she's going off
uh there was one time that I sent Dina
just won Blitz Games and she just went
in mine she said she had nightmares that
night I would love to do that because I
always I have so many like I play so
well and then I just one move one
inaccuracy and I throw away everything
so that would actually that would be a
really cool YouTube video too I would
love that yeah and I think it there's
nothing like more instructive from like
an emotional standpoint than your own
mistakes it's just you alert it hits
different honestly when you learn from
your own end game mistakes so I'll do
that for next time so it's white to play
here
and my sort of tip when you get into
Pawn end games is to start with a kind
of bird's eye view in the sense that you
you kind of need to forecast what you
think is going to happen that helps you
avoid getting overwhelmed because it
seems like oh there's a ton of options
and I can move my king and I can move my
pawns but it's pretty easy to sort
through uh the wrong moves here if you
kind of know where this is going so
where do you anticipate this end game
going
how do you anticipate it kind of ending
read the End Game ending what does
what does and what is white likely to
achieve and how is black likely to
respond to that
ah okay
well I would fix this Pawn so that your
king cannot move and then just hope that
I block this and it's exactly and we
take this guy and black guys Black's
only try is going to be to go after what
pawn this H Pawn exactly so you're
likely going to get a pawn race between
an epon and an h-bond and you've already
identified all the correct moves how
would you start
E3 go ahead
black is in zugspawn only one pawner
waiting move remaining
and now
H4 is mainly moved and the side that is
the last to exhaust its waiting move is
the winning side because the opposing
side is in zuk Swan
yep so now black has to give up the pawn
yep you take the pawn oh I see because I
was how the fun begins ah okay because
when I looked at this I was like well
this is losing for white because white
has to conquer five squares black has to
do four but you keep the king trapped
exactly but the critical moment occurs
after King H3 this is the Beautiful
um well not specifically sorry it's on
the next move that the cool moment
occurs wow
now you basically have only one try to
win the game for white
um well of course pushing but I would
consider King F3 first
yeah but if King F3 then we dance
yeah okay you just go backwards right
and you have to repeat moves you don't
ruin anything here yeah so nothing
happens yeah nothing happens
okay so we try E4 right
now if black plays King G2 and clears
the path for the pawn then it's very
easy white plays what
um we push you push and we're careful
before you push there's an easier nope
nope nope nope
um ah we win the pawn exactly remember
with Pawn races that it's not you don't
have to sort of shut your eyes and push
the pawn automatically you can use your
king in many cases to uh make it as
difficult as possible for your opponent
to push puns that allows you to win
Tempi which in turn enables you to win
the punish or sometimes you can simply
win the pawn with your king
okay
so black has to start with the move H4
and this is the critical moment
Savion went wrong here
um well I mean there's only two moves
you consider this and this this and this
exactly
so again my intuition here is misleading
like I think if you apply your intuition
you come up with the wrong move
mind you're trying to say this first
okay
King down and now if I do this you go
back
I could
I could um push
then your king would move out of the way
well actually no you would push the pawn
just came where the way we went upon
um and then I would do this again to
force you down yeah oh and now the king
wait
oh wait a second then I push and then
you push and now you're still mating
yourself exactly
move the king then you move the king out
of the way then I do this and I bet
there's like a sneaky Checkmate unless
you promote to a knight you probably
promote to a queen but black promotes
first shoot your calculation was perfect
no no you you all the errors are correct
but black promotes first in that line
yeah yeah and black makes a dream oh
yeah that's not good we don't want that
we don't want to draw so let's make the
moves on the board so that maybe
everybody in the chat could follow what
you just calculated yes and we are only
doing this because we care about the
chat and that's because I want to run
for the chess streamer of the year and
chat today is about you guys so this is
for you guys otherwise we wouldn't do
this so command vote please okay all
right so King yeah same with my my
stream I'll link I'll link to the
streamer Rewards and then don't worry
Donia when you're in the nominations I
will vote for you I just have to win
this year I won't care about the next
just this year this year next year is
all about Donya
okay so King down then um we followed
the king if you do wait Frick no I
up okay that also works so so
King H2 now let's say we play E5
yep
um we push and again why not King G1
first
don't forget about this exactly very
important to remember this in Pawn races
like if white pushes then what happens
um
if white pushes
then King here and oh this is what we
just looked at so King's here and now if
you do this you just push so it doesn't
really matter
so then I push you push
I push and you push with check exactly
and black draws the side it's not just
about the side that promotes first in my
I had a video on Pawn race is where I
talked about like the checking Zone when
you anticipate a pond race the first
thing you have to identify is if your
king is in the checking zone of the pawn
what does that mean that means you look
at the promotion score of the pawn and
you trace the diagonal that it promotes
on and you make sure that your king
isn't on that diagonal which here it is
is there does that make sense a word for
this Pawn Strat you need like you know
there's the square this this one needs a
cool name I call it the the checking
zone of the pawn we'll take it which is
uh you know I'm not really known for my
originality you gotta work on the
wording but we'll we'll sell it yeah I
think it's it's good it's a good good
standing now if white tries to entrap
Black's King here you correctly
identified why this is a draw
um all right the king just goes here
and now he's trapped so we push and you
think that you're gonna get it but now
unfortunately just
two one square too late and he's in fact
even if it was white to move two squares
too late yeah although it would be
winning if it was white to move and
you'll see why after we go down the
correct line so as intuitive as king F3
is how do you rule it out intuitively
well it's because first of all you have
to be aware of the stalemate idea but
also King F3 steps into the checking
zone of Black's H1 so you actually end
up losing a Tempo by making that move
let's consider the other candidate move
um
I mean of course there's pushing but
pushing
let's consider it okay yeah we'll
consider it
um
yeah okay pushing's only move I was
looking at King here but you just push
and it merely helps black push the point
right yeah so this is only move pushing
mm-hmm
okay so let's say they do the same thing
because if they bring the king we do the
same thing so they have to push very
good we don't want to try this idea so
let's say we push yeah
um here I'll try to force myself to
calculate and then I'll play it out for
the chat okay
um good call King comes here
and let's say we just go for the push
and you push and I push then you push
and I promote
and now we're not in the checking Zone
you promote it's right to move in that
position
yep which gives you some promise
um so you could check here you could
check here I like
uh bang bang let's see Bang Bang
I mean it looks dryish to me I'm
thinking if we check the king here the
King has to defend the queen so I'd have
to go to G1 okay
and then we I mean oh check King comes
here no this isn't gonna lead to
anything check the king would Escape
here let's make the moves on the board
not because you can't visualize but just
because there's an important concept
that is just I think worth okay talking
over generally and it'll help you seeing
the position so promote promote you can
make
[Music]
and queen so sorry oh sorry you wanted
to go back yeah no promote promoters is
correct so there is a concept here uh a
Target position where you've pushed
Black's King to the bottom row and then
you make a quiet move with your own king
and the theme is domination you dominate
The King and the queen with your own
king and queen and the reason that can
be hard to figure out is because
intuitively you assume that if it's
Black's move they will always have some
sort of a check but that's not always
the case
so how do you push black skin to the
first row
uh in the most effective way possible
G1 is the goal
yeah well one idea I had was like well
if we did this and this and then but the
queen down here to trap the king but the
issues that the queen would escape and
check us so Queen E4 also allows King H2
what's the other tempting check here
that you could contemplate this check
yep and that's doesn't allow King H2 why
not it does the job right away oh sorry
and what if King H3
um then check like here and we made on
G3 bingo so King G1 is forced and now
the Crux of the whole position
like this I see I see King G3
interesting yeah I don't know why I I
was I was looking at this concept but
for some reason my brain I can only get
there in two moves but you could just do
it right away
so King G3 and black screen is fully
dominated you're threatening a million
mates and if I play Chuck
and what do you think just be careful
not to stalemate him yeah King takes F3
and you win maybe xqc would take the
queen but we on this chat in the best
chess streamer chat would take with the
game absolutely
so that is the kind of Target concept
here where even though
black is forcibly promoting it doesn't
matter because you're using this idea of
of Total Domination
nice
um and this is very very applicable I
think to a lot of different types of end
games because what it allows you to do
is figure out a exception to a certain
Rule now you're familiar I assume that a
corner Pawn on the second rank usually
draws against a queen
yes because
because of the stalemate ideas yes now
if the white king in this position were
to be on A8 then that would be a draw
that concept makes sense
oh but because the king's close enough
if it's sufficiently close you can use
the concept we just talked about to
force Victory how would you go about it
um like in his position right now yes
white to play and this position has
occurred a million times a specific
position I promote
and now we just do what we just
transpose we came into check King G1 and
here and King G3 winning the game
exactly nice
but in the game we considered you know
you're not supposed to try to block
black skin with your king because if you
look at it concretely it actually turns
out to be counterproductive because you
step into the checking zone of Black's
Pawn
wait you're not supposed to box Oh you
mean from the oh oh the position that we
just looked at like yeah yeah King F3
was wrong in that position right because
it gets yeah so if you chase the king
down the file this is a checking Zone
got it it's like the tow away Zone you
know have you ever been towed Donya I
have been towed once and the story is
funny I was doing a 24-hour stream
oh and this is back in in Stanford and
uh that's the only way he would get
towed is like doing something wholesome
no but here's the funny thing I was
doing 24-hour stream it was my first one
and I took a five minute break to to get
some Starbucks for obvious reasons so I
went to get Starbucks and because I want
to sleep for as much as possible exactly
right so I'm like the minutes are
ticking so on my way back I parked
carelessly I didn't notice where I
parked the next morning it was Saturday
morning I went out
and I don't see my car and you know that
feeling that that sinking Horrible No it
all too well this week oh yeah I've
heard I've heard it the father you're
missing your son you're looking up and
down it was horrible because
what the procedure is where you live but
in the Bay Area you have to go to the
police station you have to pay like 150
then you have to Uber to the tow yard
they send me to the wrong tow yard
because there were two locations and
it's like in the Bay Area I mean
everything's 600 or something like that
I mean at that the value of my car was
less than 600 I had a 97 Lexus with 250
000 miles this is very similar to my
Honda
so what happened uh in your case sorry
to make you relive well no it was the
same story that the cops based LAPD
stored my Honda I had Uber to the towing
Zone I don't know why they towed it well
I kind of know why well I don't really
know why honestly it remains a mystery
and it was just a very upsetting feeling
went outside looking for my Honda and it
was gone
California man
I know
well now you've escaped it yeah no
parking problems here that's the one
redeeming texture
uh don't have to leave 30 minutes
earlier so I'll just remember this will
be the tow away Zone yeah
that's what I'm calling it so how do you
feel you're up for another position I I
know this is like one more Super
conceptually conceptually hard so
um
so we're gonna take a look at a position
um to sort of cap off one of the themes
of all these positions which is that
when you kind of try to think randomly
or you try to trust your gut instinct
often it gets very overwhelming because
you're like you don't know what's going
on it's like this position just seems to
be super technical but a lot of these
technical looking positions can actually
be deciphered if you think about them
very methodically and you start by
making observations you figure out your
opponent's defensive ideas and sometimes
that leads you directly to the correct
move I love this position it's not a
famous game at all it's like 2200 versus
2100.
it's white to play
and white has only one only one winning
move everything else is a draw
and the most obvious move the move that
your hand is literally reaching to play
with white because in my case leads to a
draw so let's start with that move what
is that incredibly obvious move at my
hand I can't help it pay it forward gang
A4
so you want to take the pawn and that's
it but it's not it because black can
easily win the C7 Pawn how
and then stop the Jeep on with this King
bang no no not like that just kidding
the night will get towed true
we've got some checks but that's not it
I mean I would oh bang bang and then
bang because it restricts the king from
defending exactly alternatively Knight
B6 Checker 95 same destination Square
and uh what can I try well white can try
King B5
but now you need to be very careful
because if white put instead brings the
bishop down
take the pawn take the Knight take is
black in the Box
um bing bing bing pot light pushes I I
thought it was a trick but we are in the
Box
wait
yeah we are yeah G4 k6 G5 yeah yeah and
you're by two tempier in the Box yes but
if white tries the tricky move King B5
you're a knowledge of theoretical end
games really helps if black tries this
move instead how should black draw this
ah I see so what would happen is even
though we're in the Box the king yes is
in opposition
yes so let's see what would we black
would win this pawn and put their King
on white excellent 93 I try the tricky
King B6
yep and we don't want to let you get
this B7 Square so we kind of C8 and
that's it you take the pawn and you
can't stop this no and then you return
and give your knight away for the last
remaining Pawn
and you give your Pawn for the last
remaining Pawn so King A4 this is how
the game ended actually white played
King A4 this 2200 played King A4 can't
blame him and black drew the game
straightforward so yep okay so what
conclusions can we make yeah those those
total end games how did he find this
only winning move so what conclusions
can we draw from that line well first of
all we know what Black's main defensive
concept is and what is the order in
which black will do it if it was black
to move here how would black go about
defending this
um either King
I mean just not here not here Knight D5
Knight takes C7 we can't stop that we
can't restrict them both of the knights
directions which by process of
elimination gives us only one concept
that we could try what does this concept
involve generally
we can't move our King We Can't Stop
black snide from winning the C7 Pawn so
we need to prevent it indirectly
which means doing what there's some
tough questions that Dania is asking
today
I keep thinking I get it and okay
indirectly stop black indirectly so not
directly so that would be
got it just give me one second
and I'm not even looking for one
specific move first I want the general
like it involves doing X and then doing
Y and you can do X in like three or four
different ways
um
I mean there's only one piece you can
move exactly you move the bishop
somewhere whatever just choose a random
make room for the pawn exactly and after
black plays night let's say Knight B6 to
prevent also King C4 white has to try
what
um pushing the pawn you have to engineer
a situation where the Knight is unable
to take the pawn because the king is no
longer in the box but here's the problem
what is black gonna play
uh well isn't this they're dry wait
So It's Tricky if we play here and then
we do this whole shebang again
right then you push we're in the box so
then the only other ideas we are in the
Box no no we are in the box so black is
trying to draw so that's the correct
move
oh yeah oh yeah right yeah yeah you are
in the box that's black yeah now the
bishop Hanks make a mental note of that
that's very important the bishop hangs
it has to waste the tempo and now
and now we trade and we are in the Box
damn it yeah by one sampo now right not
by two Tempe by one tempo yeah so why is
black in the Box well it's because black
gained the tempo on the bishop move so
now we modify the idea such that there
is no Tempo move by the Knight and
logically there's only one square that
the bishop could move to to make that
happen
here excellent Bishop H2 because we
tried Bishop F4 right yeah but if you
play Bishop B5 if you play Bishop B5 how
is black going to draw this
um well I don't think King here actually
does anything because so here there's
yeah then we move back here there's a
really cool night maneuver so you do
play Knight E7
yep white plays G4 if black plays Knight
D5 then white wins with what move
um
push push exactly take push but black
can make a different Tempo move and get
the Knight around to E6 if black gets
the Knight to E6 then you stop G5 and
threaten Knight takes C7 simultaneously
how does black do that oh he attacks the
Bish and then you have check and then
exactly Knight C6 Bishop moves check
here here
and on the next move you take the pawn
and you are still in the box
so the only winning move is Bishop to H2
it's a lot so how does this work let me
try to defend this you'll win this with
black I have to start the process with
the Knight
okay we would continue our plan push
time push time
and you attack
and then I push push time Knight takes
C7 now loses doesn't work and so finally
you've broken the defense well I have to
go back to E7 but now we casually win
this game by doing what now it's finally
time to do what we wanted to start
really we continue the plan we take this
one we take the spawn so black has to
shuffle black is totally paralyzed he is
paralyzed yes so let's say Knight G6 and
what's the actual Final Phase of the
winning plan how do we actually
end this game
uh how do we end him ah no
bang bang
um well my first idea was oh we trapped
the night and the night would come here
maybe there's a suksvang we don't even
need to we have a more straightforward
plan now remember we just bring the king
we bring the king don't try to dislodge
the king from C8 because obviously
that's not possible physically yeah
which means we need to keep the bishop
anchored to the pawn
and just use our King to dislodge the
night the night is extremely restricted
and how it's able to defend so just get
your kingdom yep okay so we just bring
the king over here yeah to do 97. I just
avoid the checks avoid owl Forks but
there aren't even any Forks yeah but at
King B7 King D7 so black is almost
already in zuk's phone
yeah okay let's say here
here
and
um now
we don't do something silly why wait
there's six is good yeah yeah never mind
yeah for some reason I thought yeah no
though yeah yeah okay yeah we pushed and
we win the only condition under which
it's drawn as you know is when the
corner Pawn of the wrong color
every other such end game is winning
um because you're just shoulder black
skiing away right
yes principles yes and that is the
winning process let me summarize
um very good you spotted Bishop H2
uh very quickly so the point is first of
all you reject the obvious move
that helps you understand what Black's
defensive strategy is which is
essentially just to take C7 with the
Knight then you say well I have to make
sure that the king is not going to be in
the box after that happens that means
you have no time to waste and you have
to move the bishop and then move the
pawn forward well you have to move the
bishop in such a way that the Knight is
not able to gain a Tempo on route to
winning the C7 pawn and logically Bishop
H2 keeps the bishop furthest away from
the Knight so it's the only winning move
everything else is a draw and they say
chess is hard it's easy like that yeah
simple very simple what could be more
straightforward than this end game
really I mean yeah no it's very in
intuitional and yeah very natural who
would ever miss that I love chess who
would ever miss them both so sure if I
was a 2200 I would see this I had um we
can uh pause here for today I had there
was one more position I had prepared in
case uh you're up for where we can uh
save it for next and what how do you how
do you feel
uh whatever you're feeling Donya
a a bathroom break please teacher
you never drink any water is it because
you're a robot no no I have like two
beverages on my desk
soda those are not good for you no soda
no this is sparkling water I I almost
never drink I love soda like I love root
beer and stuff but I almost never do it
and iced tea is like my probably my
biggest beverage of choice those are the
the top Grand Master drinks that's
Hopkins usually coffee but I haven't I
haven't had coffee in a couple days
actually
couple days
ah I'm on a reset
you've been through some dark times
yeah literally no pun into the coffee
all right okay so there's some crazy
mind-blowing positions that we'll we'll
save for next time this one I think is
manageable it is okay well obviously it
is black to move
and your goal is very obvious you have
to decide between two possible moves
what are they okay
uh either King E5 or King E7 King E5 or
King E7 which way should black go I'll
let you think about it one move loses
one move gives black a draw
okay
um one move loses okay crazy idea but
the only forcing move that this the only
person that I consider here is D4
because the pawn would have to take then
I would take the Rook then the king
would take and then king would come to
E3 tying this pawn and then this king oh
wait yes it can defend the pawn then the
king would just come there depending
upon but I feel like there's some crazy
suksbang here
um because we would push this Pawn
let's say you I would have to do some
counting here but like you push you push
oh I think we need to push it once but
like we would put them in this Pawn
oh God okay yeah yeah I don't know
you're saying all the right things
somewhere lead somewhere and then we
would take the pawn I I can see it ends
like with the pawns here these guys are
blocked we take this guy and the King's
here
so it really depends if we have the
tempo or not so two things
um first of all you're absolutely
correct that D4 check is the move which
has to be considered but the point of
this move isn't really to put black and
zugs on what you should understand about
this resulting Pawn end game it's
winning but it doesn't matter even if
white can cause zougsong what you should
notice here is which side has the
outside pass Pawn eyes why does the
outside passer but there's a second
thing you when you're trying to create a
pass Pawn you have to be extremely
careful about allowing your Pawn stick
to be deep Frozen
so which Pawn would you start with how
do you actually create the passer on the
queen side
with the bee Pawn why not A4
A4 you push A5 yeah so this is what you
have to avoid the rule is usually to
push the perspective password so you
identify which Pawn is ultimately going
to be the passer well it's obviously the
B Pawn because both sides of an a pawn
so you push the pass Pawn First that
guarantees that you won't be caught in a
deep freeze
so go ahead
um
uh uh wait what what do you mean well so
which move would white play here oh you
can make moves
oh oh sorry so in this position you mean
this one yep let's say black bushes and
The crucial bit is that it doesn't even
matter how many waiting moves black has
it it's not about zugs long it's about
the fact that you are going to create
that passer and force Black's King to
abandon all of the king side pawns
continue
um I don't think it matters here if you
push A4 or B5 so either works B5 is I
would say even more clinical yeah
um now I bring this guy in and obviously
this Pawn race F4 takes takes A5 is just
easily winning for white black is not
even close so that's it I mean let's say
I go King E6
take
King D6
that's it the game is not working E6
actually here you don't even need to
deflect black skin you can just straight
up promote
yeah B6 a b
uh even no even simpler yeah no no A6
outside pass pawns outside but a b also
wins right this is important to
understand because here you very simple
right winning plan deflection so in pawn
and games the outside pass Pawn is
probably the single most important thing
to identify or the potential to create
one because ironically black is the side
that has two pass bonds white has zero
past pawns but it's still winning and
you should determine that intuitively
because you should sense that white will
inevitably create the past spawn on the
side of the board
okay and that is exactly how black lost
the game we're talking about a 20 2057
feet a so not you know some uh rating
amateur off the street so actual strong
players make these mistakes now why did
he reject King E7 intuitively well
what's the reason that King E7 doesn't
seem appealing well for sure blundering
the pawn with check
yep with check if it wasn't check you'd
be able to go Rook F2 and Rook takes H2
but just because you're a pawn down
doesn't mean the game is over in fact
this is an easy draw because black is
threatening to infiltrate right yep and
if white tries to stop here there is a
very important defensive Motif where you
just check him infinitely and White's
King cannot cover all of the
infiltration squares
oh you just keep going back and forth
you're going back and forth and if
White's King go ahead
and if White's King runs to G4
and we come behind the pawn yeah your
Rook gets active you take B2 take the
skin and even though you're a pawn down
it's a draw because black is Super
Active and can create a second pass so
this is pretty easy easy draw to make
white cannabin move his King because the
H2 Pawn is going to be lost
yep and if the king tried to go to like
G1 then I'm guessing then the square
that we want to control is the East two
square Bingo yes exactly you always go
back always being here yeah and last
thing I'll point out here is let's say
white goes for K5 you can also play
rookie two but one technique you should
be aware of is to basically go behind
the pawn in order to be able to capture
it with check oh interesting
yeah which also should draw so rookie
two draws with a with I think a similar
Motif what should black do here
um as my coach would say always give a
check in the end game it's like almost
always gonna be a good thing you would
just do the same thing just but not here
not here it was a better move no no no
we have this oh oh check first and then
take this guy and then take the pawn and
if white goes the other way
uh this way then you take this guy yeah
you take beat you and you're threatening
Checkmate you gained it so this is
better than taking right away just
because we gained one tempo and that one
tempo makes the difference yeah yes
because we're threatening you're
threatening me yeah so white has to
respond to that either by bringing the
Rook down and now I would say like why
does the one defending or if King G2
what's hilarious is you do the same
thing again and white could lose this
way
because like now you take A2 and again
you're threatening mate got it but and
if you didn't check is it still a draw
if you don't give the check where
uh like if we just take right away so
here instead of checking I guess you're
losing the spawn so that's why it's
probably still a draw yeah the end the
engine gives it's not complicated but no
even even you could take the spawn
immediately because the reality is even
if you play I think Rook to D2 usually
and you probably know this two-on-ones
with Rooks are usually draws unless the
pawn is super far Advanced or something
yes
unless the pawn is super far Advanced
it's it's generally speaking a draw
yeah I'm not very good at these end
games neither I mean I don't think
anybody is this is like always hard to
defend so you should try to avoid the
scenario impossible but just so you know
like even if you do quote unquote all
the wrong things it's still a draw
you'd be surprised you'd be surprised of
my Blitz Games but that'll be for next
stream I lost I've lost a lot of these
types of end games so
don't worry
yeah so obviously I have tons of
positions and uh we could you know go
between tactics and and conceptual
positions but I think ultimately the
biggest misconception with endgame
Improvement not that I know is probably
against my weakest point is that there
are all of these Concepts that are
applicable in Rook end games you know
keep your Rook behind the pawn and most
nothing you already know so at this
point in your chest development I think
a lot of it is literally just treating
end games the same way that you treat
tactics and just solving a crap ton of
different positions because pattern
recognition in the end game is much more
important of a concept than I think
people realize people think it's all
Concepts but really a lot of end game
Mastery is just recognizing patterns
just like you do when let's say you
solve chess.com puzzles
got it so pushing them like Puzzles
approaching them like Puzzles and
appreciating the role of tactics and
calculation in the end game which is
what we've kind of focused on the first
few times
so very nice it's tough It's a Grind
that's why end games
for my YouTube intro absolutely please
do please do
okay well I will release you from the
torture Andrea but this is super super
fun I hope you know positions weren't
too crazy no these are always great I I
do like these they were the last two
were quite crazy but they all make sense
and you pitch them in a fun way which I
didn't think you could do so this is
good I appreciate that and you know as
long as you understand the logic uh
behind the solution and can derive like
any sort of General uh less than whether
it's a pattern that you now know or a
certain type of idea like here for
example right the concept of
sacking upon to change the pawn
structure is really important to create
the outside Pawn Yeah so yes these small
lessons they add up when you solve a
thousand positions you'll start
recognizing these patterns in your games
and definitely I've got a lot more fun
positions so I'd always be down for part
three yeah but I think good spot to call
it a day for now
thank you so much Dania are you going to
continue streaming I'll stream for a bit
yeah
okay sounds good see if we finish before
you I probably I'll probably take a
break so I'll actually I'll probably end
the stream and radio and then but I'll
definitely be back tonight you're very
funny you always do two streams in one
day you should just put on like an
internal starting soon signs yeah you do
we'll be back for like an hour about
that
yeah they won't know no one will know
all right thank you Andrea it's a
pleasure you're you know you're awesome
your community is awesome so I'm always
happy to do this and uh looking forward
to part three sounds good I'll put in my
vote
okay please do it's very important we
need your vote we need it every vote
counts Donnia you got it I'll send you
the raid pretty soon
okay thank you Dania have a good morning
you too great session bye
thank you
[Music]